afternoon everybody good afternoon
get everybody in
you guys can get along the side there so
feel
ings
well good afternoon everyone we're
holding this press conference today
really to bring people up to date I know
there's still questions
about what is going on in East Palestine
we've tried throughout this to continue
to inform the public everyone but most
particularly the people who are directly
affected so today I brought many members
of our team together to talk about the
current monitoring that is going that's
underway and to really answer outs to
any outstanding questions that may still
be out there today I have experts from
the Ohio Environmental Protection Agency
the Ohio Department of Health the Ohio
Department of Natural Resources the Ohio
Department of Agriculture Ohio
Department of Public Safety Ohio
Emergency Management agency the Ohio
Department of Transportation and the
Public Utilities Commission of Ohio
they're all in the room with me today
let me go back to February 3rd 8 55 PM
when the train wreck occurred while
traveling through East Palestine on
Friday Night February 3rd in North
Southern Train derailed causing a
massive fire around 50 railroad cars
were impacted by the crash including 10
that were hauling hazardous materials in
addition to the fire there's also
serious environmental concerns U.S EPA
and the Ohio PA work to slow the flow of
contaminated water while firefighters
work to extinguish The Blaze
by that Sunday two days later
concerns began to arise in regard to the
temperature in one of the cars I was on
a conference call that night around 7 30
when that information was first given to
me
uh
based on the conversations that I was
hearing and information
it was clear that more assistance was
needed in that East Palestine and so I
activated the Ohio National Guard to go
there which which they did very very
quickly I was also informed on that call
about the car where the temperature was
very described as very volatile and at
that moment was in fact Rising
uh the fear was that this car might
explode sending deadly shrapnel
in all directions
the next morning I traveled to at East
Palestine
and met with those on the ground
those who had been working those who
represented the railroad
as well as the the federal government
it was clear at that point that we were
faced with two bad options one option
was to do nothing and wait for the car
to explode
I had discussion uh with the
representatives of the railroad and
extended discussion I brought a
Pennsylvania Governor Shapiro in that
through my cell phone and we went back
and forth for a couple hours trying to
just weigh the risk one versus the other
uh
the risk of the car exploding was
described to me as as high
uh high probability that it could
explode
and when I pressed everyone to give me
the information about and and also give
Governor Shapiro the information she was
on on the cell phone listening and
asking questions
it came back that the concern was that
this would be a catastrophic what was
described as a catastrophic explosion of
the of the car uh which would result in
shrapnel uh going out up to close to
close to a mile
uh we also looked at
what the danger was from a controlled
release which is what the railroad felt
should be done again Governor Shapiro
and I uh spent uh considerable time up
to about two hours I recall
asking a lot of questions about how that
would take place we had the benefit of
the Ohio National Guard that had done a
modeling
exercise
they did that in conjunction with the
U.S defense department
who gave them some additional
information and help in regard to the
modeling the modeling was then produced
into a map a map I believe that we
showed everyone that day when we had our
press conference there was a red area
that they described as the likelihood of
death within that red area would be very
high there was a little there's an area
outside that the yellow area where they
also described it would be very
dangerous to be there but not quite as
dangerous as it was within the red
within the red area
we then made the decision to go ahead
with the the second option which was the
controlled release
as that was being prepared to be done
we sent back law enforcement into those
zones the Red Zone and the yellow zone
for the third time to knock on literally
knock on doors
and they described how they did it to me
they did it in in very loud did
everything they could do to get if
there's anyone left in that house to get
their attention to to come out that was
the third time that those houses I
believe had been had been contacted the
individuals in those houses have been
contacted
the controlled release did did it in
fact uh occur it was it was to my
understanding delayed a little bit
there was actually when we at three
o'clock the release was supposed to be
at 3 30 we want to get everybody out of
there we had members of the guard and
the patrol and others who were had the
area cordon off we told them to leave
there at three o'clock uh unfortunately
there's a couple cars that came in and
we had to go they had to go get them out
of that in of that impacted area or what
would be an impacted area so the the
release occurred as I recall about 4 15
and we you know were monitoring the air
outside that area and the air continued
to be continued to be good
fast forward to the time when we opened
it back up a couple days later
we had sent in members of the Ohio
National Guard and and had their had
their protective suits on to measure the
air and no one went back with in that
area or was allowed back in that area
until they could come back and tell us
that the monitoring was consistently
good in fact the monitoring showed that
the air was basically what it was prior
to the actual train crash of what we
would have expected it to be at that
time people were then let let back back
in our environmental teams remain in
East Palestine where they're working
directly with the railroad and others to
ensure that the site is thoroughly
cleaned up with no shortcuts uh this
morning I called Alan Shaw CEO of
Norfolk Southern he and I have had
contact numerous times since the crash I
discussed with him and the concerns that
we're hearing from residents uh
residents of East Palestine I asked him
directly directly if he would personally
guarantee if he would personally
guarantee that the railroad would stay
there until absolutely everything was
cleaned up he gave me his word and his
commitment that the railroad would do
that they would not leave until that was
done
I might also mention that I received a
call from President Biden earlier last
week he told me
that he was wanted just to assure me
that anything I needed from the federal
government they would Supply and told me
to call him personally if there was
anything that we needed at any point I
told the president that I appreciated
the work that we'd received so far from
the U.S EPA I also told him that I
appreciated the help that the defense
department gave the Ohio National Guard
in regard to the modeling that it was
very very helpful and I expressed my
gratitude for that
let me also say that uh
JD Vance and Congressman Johnson have
been in touch with me in fact I just
talked to both of them a moment ago
again
they've expressed their interest in
doing anything that needs to be done I
know Senator Brown has as as well
and let me just now talk about something
that I did learn today which I think
does impact Congress
uh I learned today from the puco Ohio
puco that this train was not was not
considered high hazardous material train
let me repeat this this train apparently
was not considered a high hazardous
material train therefore the railroad
was not required to notify anyone here
in Ohio about what was in the rail cars
coming through our state I would think
that the members of Congress and I would
ask them to take a look at this even
though some rail cars did have hazardous
material on board
and while most of them did not that's
why it was not
categorized as a high hazardous material
train frankly uh if this is true and I'm
told it's true this is absurd and we
need to look at this and Congress needs
to take a take a look at how these
things are handled we should know when
we have trains here carrying hazardous
material that are going through the
state of Ohio
so I asked Congress to take a look at
this and again see what they can find
out and if those facts as I related them
are true to take the appropriate action
so let me now get down to sharing the
information that we have let me just
State again we will continue to do this
we're not leaving either we're not
leaving at East Palestine until
everything is done and we have as I
indicated a number of agencies from the
state of Ohio that have been involved
and they will continue to be involved as
we we move forward let me now ask Mary
murch the director of the Ohio
Department of Natural Resources to come
up I think Steve Gray was going to come
up as well and discuss
the question about the dead fish I know
that people have been seeing the dead
fish they want to know what you know
what is going on whether that is
continuing and continuing to be a
problem and I've asked the director of
Department of Natural Resources to talk
about that and talk about some of the
streams that are in fact impacted from
there we will go I will introduce her in
a moment but a representative from from
the Ohio Environmental Protection Agency
who will also talk about the the water
quality and we'll move from there to the
water into the air
director Mertz
start off to give you just a little bit
of context about the waterways we're
talking about where they are and how the
water flowed so I think Steve's going to
help me out here so so the initial water
impact was sulfur run are we able to can
you find that on there or do we need to
use the map in your hand so
so the okay so so above this map we have
a smaller map here the initial impact
was at sulfur run leading down into
Leslie run to Bull Creek and then a
portion of the North Fork of Beaver
Creek so we essentially so for our
purposes we looked at four different
waterways over a space of about seven
and a half miles and what the
environmental impacts were on those
streams and tributaries well I imagine
director what's beyond that as we move
towards the Ohio River
so so the North Fork of Beaver Creek
leads into Beaver Creek which I'm lost I
mean we eventually get down there
so yeah it does go directly into the
Ohio River yeah go for it so the North
Fork of Beaver Creek goes into the main
stem of Little Beaver Creek which is a
state Scenic River and then that flows
into the Ohio River
so that's the essential geography we
were looking at for this and you know
the Department of Natural Resources are
part of our mission is to preserve and
improve Ohio's biodiversity so our
concern in this case was what was
happening with the Aquatic wildlife
and what we have discovered through the
testing and sampling that's been done is
that very early on
um you know we we have estimated based
on our sampling and modeling about 3 500
dead fish across that space across those
streams tributaries waterways
12 different species the good news is
that none of those species are
threatened or endangered but that is
still a loss of wildlife so of concern
especially when we reach the Beaver
Creek this state wild in Scenic River
where we are especially protective of
what we have there
so some of the species Creek chub model
sculpin Stone roller I think we have
some pictures somewhere of what those
are but 12 different species
non-threatened or endangered but still a
loss of life all the same the one
species we will be looking for we have
no evidence yet that any have died but
this is really an area of focus for
Hellbenders Which are federal and state
endangered and so we will be doing some
monitoring in the months to come to see
if any of them did die in the initial
release into the waterways
so good news there doesn't appear to be
any increase in the fish or aquatic
creatures killed since the first couple
days of the derailment so Wildlife
officers have been there every day on
the scene working with contractors who
are in the water doing the net sampling
making the estimates and we will
continue to Monitor and and watch what's
going on and eventually hold those
responsible accountable for the loss of
wildlife in the area
we don't have any evidence of
non-aquatic species suffering from the
derailment haven't haven't had any
concerns about that not only here but we
also communicate with the Pennsylvania
Game Commission as well and they haven't
heard about that either so
um that is essentially where we are with
the Department of Natural Resources and
I think the governor record thank you
thank you very much you'll be available
for questions let me invite now Tiffany
cavallack from the Ohio Environmental
Protection Agency to come to the
microphone we have on the screen from
East Palestine Kohler Kurt you may
remember at a previous two press
conferences was available and discussed
what the situation was we're asking them
to tell us the very latest measurements
coming from from the site
thank you thank you
hello I'm Tiffany kavalock I'm the chief
of the division of surface water at Ohio
EPA and speaking of the derailment on
February 3rd we speak that it occurred
at the location of sulfur run and
Norfolk and Southern are actively
aerating sulfur run and have containment
within the 1.3 miles that sofa run leads
into Leslie run
sofa run remains contaminated but we're
confident that it is contained
data from February 4th the day after the
trained derailment downgradient on
Leslie run and Norfolk Little Beaver
Creek showed very low detection levels
of contaminants and mostly from fire
residual chemicals
data from February 10th more recently
showed low levels of only two
contaminants
butyl acrylate and ethyl hexyl acrylate
both are volatile organic organic
chemicals
in Leslie run
the one that's directly below sulfur run
the butyl acrylate dissipates to
non-detectable levels once it gets to
the North Fork of the Little Beaver
Creek and the other one ethyl hexole
acrylate dissipates to non-detectable
levels once we get to Little Beaver
Creek
we have not detected any vinyl chloride
in any of the down gradient waterways
both the February 4th and the February
10th data are available now on Ohio
epa's website that's titled East
palestine's train derailment
The Spill did flow to the Ohio River
during that initial Slug and but the
Ohio river is very large and it's a
water body that's able to dilute the
pollutants pretty quickly
Ohio EPA and other state agencies have
been working with the Ohio River Valley
Water Sanitation commission some may
know as orsenko
to track the contaminant plume in real
time
it's moving at about a mile an hour
or senko's tracking allows for potential
closing of drinking water intakes to
allow the majority of the chemicals to
pass
this strategy along with drinking water
treatment like oxidation and advanced
treatment like activated carbon are both
effective at addressing these
contaminants and helps ensure the safe
drink safety of the drinking water
supplies
so we're pretty confident that these low
levels are are not getting passed on to
the customers
let me explain how you talked about the
containment uh what steps were taken to
to contain it in in that initial spill
yes and I think that's why we have I
think do that okay good
Kurt yeah yeah we want to answer that uh
Kurt and then you can kind of give us a
report from East Palestine
okay I'll be glad to thank you sir
um and I'll uh where again you you're
hearing the results you hear us speak
about it before at the beginning of the
spill we were on a defensive posture as
the governor to kind of talked about it
was safety first she had an attack from
the outside in since the conditions have
changed the removal that threats from
the rail cars the cleanup in the
emergency phase that has been on the
offensive not only with multiple
containment points and Institute
treatment uh in salt for one uh with
Norfolk Southern and our other partners
kind of as a management plan for this
cleanup under again the emergency phase
where we targeted three sites or we used
three different names for it we had the
record chair where the cars are still
being staged we have pleasant roads
where we do know we have gross
contamination present on the ground and
still in the two ditches and we have the
waterways
have been our targeted they are
concerned from the onset of this we did
get initial date parents dirt dumped
into the creek to stop the flow or the
Booms that will containment rooms to
stop the colonial product from that
point in time we did use very tried and
true methods but we've been able to
build those up aeration and sparging
units that increase the efficiency of
the breaking down of the dissolved phase
of the
of the contaminants present we do again
a software run we have it contained we
it is our controlling area we're
confident that the material is getting
out of there and extending down the less
we run our
good
there is residual material and let's see
when that's some of the explanation why
there is still uh some of the detections
we do have aeration in Leslie run that
site like a Pleasant Road or the beetle
car uh did release material along with
the vinyl chloride burn areas they're an
aqueous excavation of those grossly
contaminated soils
two ditches that run parallel to the
tracks Norwich and South ditch were both
ran into uh salt program have been
blocked off the water that naturally
flows in there from the Wetland is being
pumped around so we don't augment any
contamination and continue to push high
levels of contaminants Downstream and
then excavation of that material has
already begun the center line of the
track where people activate was puddled
along with vinyl chloride residues is
actively being excavated
um it is a constant Source reduction but
again with the target of moving over
into the remediation phase we're trying
to get rid of again of the the
high-level gross contamination or how he
pays emergency response along with other
support from our multiple divisions have
boots on the ground all day every day
since the onset of this incident I'm
confident that we'll get it to a stage
where it's safe to transfer over for
remediation
Kurt thank you very much uh let me ask
you one one question uh and then then if
you'll stay around because the media may
have some questions for you when we
finish
how far along is this removal of dirt my
understanding it's uh you're going
they're going down one to three feet
down into the ground but but how how far
along are they in regard to that
but current volumes we have about uh
almost a million gallons of water
collected it's been stored in various
contained storage uh containers on site
from a liquid waste standpoint and that
is from the solids if I remember there's
almost 500 cubic yards of vinyl chloride
impact of material that Center alignment
of track is again an emergency response
we do the you know there was awareness
that there was matured on the surface
and extending down the goal of this was
to get rid of that highly contaminated
potentially mobile material before we
had rain events or something like that
that can drive it further down this
initial phase some of these pits sir are
now 700 feet long and about eight foot
deep in some areas and this main
excavation going now is there's some
stability issues so I think they're
they're recording about four to five
feet below ground surface down to a hard
packed clay
and that is going all the way from
Pleasant Road into the where the main
dilemma occurred so they were in the
range of the thousand foot or more
do you have any idea uh what percentage
of the work is done yet roughly
from the emergency response phase that
someone we're working we still have are
action items the ditches the center line
uh again the Waterway is is primary it's
moving along I would hope next week a
lot of the emergency response phase this
high-end daily activity should start to
drop off
Kurt thank you
stay on there in case we get questions
thank you very much appreciate it
appreciate the work you're doing let me
now introduce Dr Bruce vanderhoff the
director of the Ohio Department of
Health uh he's going to talk about
exactly where we are in regard to the
air the water
and everything from the public health
point of view and Dr vanderhoff one of
the things I would ask you to address is
the odor I know people are still seeing
smelling an odor uh and I want wonder if
you can uh you know comment about that
and what the significance of that is
well thank you governor
let's begin uh by just talking about the
chemicals and the fact is that for the
most part most of the chemicals that
we're worried about and that we're
talking about fall into a category known
as volatile organic chemicals you heard
that mentioned uh for or compounds now
volatile organic compounds or vocs it's
important for us to recognize are
actually a part of our everyday life
so if you go this afternoon on your way
home to pump gas in your car
you're being exposed to volatile organic
compounds you are if you are burning
wood or natural gas in your home you're
being exposed and certainly if you are
smoking or you live with someone who
smokes you're being exposed to actually
fairly substantial levels of volatile
organic compounds now the good news is
that most people can be around these
volatile organic compounds at low levels
without really feeling health effects
however at higher levels especially over
a longer period of time then we can have
longer-term health effects and that's
why there is the concern around these
compounds
so the goal from a health point of view
in a situation like this is really to
make
to reduce the risk that we're going to
take those valid organic compounds into
our bodies and they're really two paths
for that to happen one is what we
breathe and the other is what we consume
so the effort as you heard it described
really began at the start with trying to
make sure that we had a safe environment
as it related to the air that people
were breathing you know
for us as as human beings we've got to
breathe we can't avoid the air the air
is there we need it and so it has to be
cleaned it has to be safe for us and the
good news is and you heard the governor
describe this by the time we were at the
decision point for potentially bringing
the people who had evacuated back into
the impacted area
we had on hand
air testing that told us that the air
really looked pretty much like it did
before this event ever happened so that
gave us really great confidence when it
came to that aspect but you know then
there's the second aspect even after
bringing people back we made it clear
that hey the next piece of this is your
water source we want to test that now
the the good news is the majority of
people who live in the East Palestine
Community are in fact on Municipal Water
and those Municipal sources are deep
Wells that they were able to
intentionally Reserve using the most
distant ones only for feeding the water
supply but nevertheless there are quite
a number of people who are on private
Water Systems mostly private Wells
we have strongly encouraged all of those
people on private Wells to get their
Wells tested and that will be done at no
cost to them this is something that is
part of the remediation and it's very
important for the reasons I just
described now if you are one of the
people who live in the impacted area and
have a private water source you're not a
Municipal Water I'd encourage you to
call a number I'll read the number out
you've heard it before it's
330-849-3919 and indicate I I believe
I'm in the affected area and I'd like to
have my water source checked now
we're strongly recommending those who
have not yet had their water source
checked
to use bottled water bottled water is
being made available again same phone
number that you can call if you need
access to that this is going to be
particularly important if you are
pregnant if you are breastfeeding or if
you are preparing formula for an infant
so we would encourage you to Avail
yourself of that of that water
the bottom line is that from the very
start of this we have taken every step
possible
to assure that people's safety was first
and foremost and that with the compounds
that we're talking about in consultation
with experts at the national level we
have first made sure that we were
providing a clean atmosphere clean air
and now we are actively working to
assure that people for the long run have
clean water thank you governor
uh we're happy to take any questions for
anyone who's uh oh yeah
hi Joe Ingles with Ohio public radio and
television my question is you said that
the water is safe at least the community
water that's been tested but should
people maybe think of using water
filters like Brita filters that kind of
thing is that a good good thing to do
right now while things are unknown and
should people just go ahead and do
bottled water in the meantime yeah at
this stage in the game we are
recommending that people in the
community consider using bottled water
there we are awaiting results
of testing of the municipal water
sources that are going to be fairly
detailed and will allow us to have a
very complete look potential compounds
that could be involved and we expect
that very soon
you know from my point of view using
bottled water for a short period of time
is pretty easy to do and once we have
data and information especially if you
have a private water source look there
are things that we will be able to do it
may be drilling a new well a deep well
instead of a shallow well it may be
using some of the remediation tools that
were described for municipal sources
that include forms of aeration and
charcoal filtering Etc so for right now
I think bottled water is the right
answer
hi this is Ashley bernanson with wbns I
also have a question for you Doctor
um in terms of that radius of those who
should be drinking bottled water how far
does that radius go could this impact
Central Ohioans and what could that
impact be on the current health of those
who might have been intaking this water
uh thank you so uh we're very confident
about uh and and there are maps in the
uh that are available in the community
of what we believe to be the impacted
zone for these Wells and and
um people call that hotline they'll be
able to access that for people more
distant I'm going to turn to some of my
colleagues from the Ohio EPA to describe
again that process of testing if you're
in central Ohio
this is really not relevant to your
water source if you're actually in most
of the rest of Ohio we're really talking
about those uh who have
municipal water sources coming off the
Ohio river and I'm absolutely confident
that or Cinco and the local communities
along with Ohio EPA and U.S EPA are
using every appropriate caution to
assure that there's no public health
impact
you want to do the Ohio River again sure
or yes it is important we we know that
there is a plume moving down the Ohio
River so our all of our neighboring
states the state departments and
oursenko are in constant communication
about the location of the plume we think
it's on its way around Huntsville or
Huntington West Virginia now and so all
of those water systems are in constant
community communication on when it may
be at their intake and they're either
shutting down and or using the Treatment
available that they have on site so we
think that's the only southern part of
the exposure that there might be from
the site
for that second part could there be any
health effects of those who have already
intaken that water
low levels of con of contaminants and so
all of the treatment being done at those
water systems
take out any contamination before it
finished water so I can't Envision that
there would be any risk that has already
occurred from the drinking water systems
on the Ohio River
I have questions about water as well so
um I I I'm Nick Evans with the Ohio
Capital Journal um I just want to make
sure that I understand what you laid out
okay so it goes Silver Run Leslie run
Beaver Creek Ohio River correct North
Fork North Fork yeah okay so you you
said that sulfur is contaminated but you
think it's contained Leslie no Vinyl
chloride but ethylbutyl and ethyl hexel
black acrylate okay what's in the plume
uh that was the initial slug that we
talked about that were the uh the fire
combustion chemicals that we detected uh
that are showing up we have data that's
on our we showed hundreds of detections
on that initial slug that went through
into the Ohio River but they're no
longer being seen in the smaller
tributaries except for those two
chemicals okay so in the plume though
it's just the the ethyl hexel and the
PewDiePie River yeah yeah yeah
um
honestly uh there's probably it's the
the fire contaminant uh combustion
materials it's it's not free product per
se it's volatile organic compounds there
could be multiple but not necessarily
just the remaining two that we're seeing
in the
in the smaller tributaries if that makes
sense yes okay you're welcome
you want to talk about the dilution at
that point in Ohio or what are you
seeing in the Ohio River so
um very very low levels of volatile
organic compounds in the Ohio River
itself
probably it helps that it has been very
diluted and we don't expect any higher
concentrations to follow than the
initial onset of the the plume that
we're tracking thank you you're welcome
um follow up on the plume when you
mentioned the fire combustion materials
or their concerns about pfas and similar
contamination so we have not yet tested
for the pfos compounds we are working
with the local
um
uh the local EMA to start testing the
pfos compounds I think in the drinking
water specifically
hi Jeremy Pelzer with cleveland.com
there have been anecdotal reports in the
media of people around East Palestine
suffering headaches other health
problems like sore throat Etc and then
in addition other Andy critical reports
about animals dying like chickens and
cats have you been able to substantiate
any of these and what do you think if
these are true are causing these yeah so
it's a it's a very good question
anecdotes are challenging because they
are anecdotes a couple of things first
of all for
many of the compounds that go on the
list of volatile organic compounds we
can smell them at levels that are well
below the levels that are considered
unsafe so it is possible that at a very
very low level you can still smell a
volatile organic compound so I don't
discount that
um
the in terms of some of the symptoms of
headache
Etc
unfortunately volatile organic compounds
share with a host of other things the
ability to cause very common symptoms at
the lower level so headache eye
irritation nose irritation
Etc I think that we have to look at the
measured facts
and the measured facts include the fact
that the air sampling in that area
really is not pointing toward an air
source for this and secondly
um
in terms of water
we're encouraging people to use bottled
water
particularly if they're on a private
water source now could somebody have a
private water source that could be
contaminated and we haven't tested it
yet well it's a voluntary program and
that is possible I would encourage them
to make a switch immediately remember
with these compounds
it's not a for in most circumstances
just about a single small exposure it's
an equation of concentration over
duration
the higher the concentration the longer
the duration the greater the risk
thus far is really pointing toward
very low measurements if at all and what
I would encourage people who are having
the symptoms to do is number one contact
your medical provider
and number two call the local hotline to
let them know that you're experiencing
this so a team can get out and check
their environment
um Senator Vance was on Fox News
critical five Administration even some
Democrats have been critical of
providing Administration response are
you satisfied with the by the
administration responses is there
anything you'd like to see more out of
Administration as far as health like
this look
um
our Ohio EPA works with the U.S EPA
these are the principal people involved
the federal government is conducting an
investigation to determine why this
wreck occurred this crash occurred we
await that and certainly will be
interested in seeing what was going on
look the president called me and said
anything you need I have not called him
back after that after that conversation
we I will not hesitate to do that if we
if we're seeing a problem or anything
but I'm not seeing it
um Patrick sagas with with the aps
probably a question for ODNR I know you
had mentioned that there weren't any
maybe like reports of animals dying
because of because of this because of
the controlled release
but again we have been hearing anecdotes
from people in the area about pets or
other agricultural animals what what can
they do if they believe that you know
their animal died because of this and
like what is ODNR doing to measure that
I think that's probably director of
Agriculture Frank baldidge thank you uh
Governor dewine thank you for that
question as far as the livestock
Community from the agricultural from
Department of AG standpoint our we've
been in contact with folks in the
community as far as the veterinarians
our state vet Dr Summers has been in
contact with folks in that community and
that's what we're telling folks if you
see symptoms of your livestock reach out
to your local vet but we are in constant
contact with them and also our
stakeholders Farm Bureau
OSU Extension all the folks in that
community and to this day there's
nothing that we've seen in the livestock
community that causes any concerns to
the state thank you
Bureau Ohio public radio and television
Governor this is for you you've said
that you fully expect Norfolk Southern
to pay all the costs you say you've
gotten a commitment from them that they
are going to stay on site till
everything's cleaned up are you
confident that they are going to pay all
those costs and there are reports of
people having trouble even cashing these
convenience uh inconvenience checks what
do you tell those folks
well look uh Norther Sovereign Southern
is responsible for this problem we fully
expect them to live up to what the CEO
committed to me and that is that they
will pay for everything
if they don't
we've got an attorney general here and
that will file a lawsuit so look they're
responsible for this they did it
um you know this is a you know the
impact on this community is huge
um the not just the physical
problem that might be caused but the
inconvenience uh that the terror
um
many many things and so yes you know
we've already seen lawsuits filed I'm
sure there'll be more lawsuits filed
but you know my objective is to do
everything we can to get this cleaned up
as quickly as quickly as we can and I
think by continuing to talk and reveal
what we're doing what the testing is
showing I hope that people will will
continue to have you know confidence in
what what's going on but you know I
understand people's skepticism and I
understand uh their anger and if you
know if I lived in the community I would
be angry too
pause this problem
they're going to be held accountable
man w
secretions pointing to deliberate
actions to make this trained derailment
I have no indication of that
as far as you know
just receive one of those checks uh
absolve the regular responses Maryland
responsibility what strings are attached
to these checks
uh well I don't want to play lawyer here
but I don't think that resolves them of
any or absolves them excuse me of any
responsibility they're still responsible
for any damage that they've caused
remember we're ready for online
questions all right we'll go to the
online questions
uh just wondering
Who besides Norfolk Southern was
consulted on in this decision to do
control release was there independent
information
collected by either the state of Ohio or
the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania that
allowed you to make a decision about the
controlled release independent of what
was being provided to you by more quick
Southern yeah we consulted as I
indicated we consulted the Ohio National
Guard was Consulting directly with the
defense department the modeling was very
important we wanted to know exactly what
the ramifications of the modeling would
be or of the explosion would be so yes
we we reached out to every expert that
certainly that we could find
next question comes from Craig Cheatham
WCPO
a several of the speakers have said
one mentioned that the contamination the
so-called plume is moving at about a
mile an hour I want to make sure that
that's it that that is correct and that
right now it's believed to be in
Huntington and so what I'm asking is how
big of a threat is that food perceived
to be for the communities that are
Downstream and how long do you believe
it will be until that plume and what's
in it reaches Cincinnati which is the
largest city
Downstream for quite some time thank you
hi thank you for your question it is on
its way to Huntington I I don't have the
exact mile markers of where it is right
now
um orsenka would be able to tell you
exactly where that location is
at this time the farther it travels down
the Ohio River the more it is
dissipating the less
the less concentrated the contaminant
plume is so the farther it heads down
the Ohio the much less risk that it is
and we haven't seen a risk even at the
most closest points to East Palestine so
we would not Envision anything from this
point forward
impacting any of the further drinking
water supplies and I will say that the
Cincinnati Water Plant themselves have
been extraordinarily helpful in tracking
the butyl acrylate chemical itself it
was a brand new chemical that we did not
have a methodology for in Cincinnati is
performing that analysis for all of the
drinking water systems north of of the
Ohio River
[Music]
next question comes from Megan Lowe with
verify
get one of our readers asked if any if
the EPA is testing any soil samples
following the derailment can you speak
to that and what the EPA has found so
far if so
I would like to turn that question over
to Kirk Kohler who's on site
I guess uh that is ongoing
um it's too full part of again that
remediation phase a what's called
geoprobe with a zebra Bush quads down
into the ground full of soil up from
ferment depth is at ongoing uh that's
going down both sides the center line of
the track both sides all the way through
Pleasant Road and Beyond the derailment
areas East uh separate soil samples have
been collected within other areas of the
vinyl chloride that part of the
characterization and preparation for
Waste Disposal and again more folk
southern it's also taking advantage of
the excavation they're planning for
again
for three more mediation efforts and
ongoing collection so yes sampling is
being done I know our division of
surface water is already properly work
plans are in place uh for both a
potential seven sampling and and
long-term surface water sampling along
the various waterways so that is in
development yes
Layman's uh question but I assume that
you're that they will not leave
and will not stop removing dirt until
they can go in and get samples of what's
remaining and and there's no no no
evidence that it's it's there is that
right I mean they're going to go back in
and make sure that when they think
they're done they'll be back in and
Sample and make sure that there's
nothing showing up
and yes sir that's uh again two-phase
approach in fact the the gross the
impact and the emergency response phase
get data value you can to build out the
long-term remediation plan for both soil
water other impact the media
thank you
our next question is from Mike Fairchild
NBC 24 tomato
in this press conference referred to
that it was absurd that this train was
not considered high hazardous uh and it
seems that in 2020 the Department of
Transportation allowed rules to be uh
relaxed I guess to allow 100 or more
tank cars filled with gallons of liquid
petroleum gas it could be also even more
dangerous what would you say to uh he
said that Congress needs to change this
is it something that you can do as a
governor to change the way these bomb
trains are transported through the state
thank you yeah my understanding when
we're dealing with a railroad Governor
sir Powers very limited this is
generally a federal government uh thing
that that we they basically preempt us
on on the control of the railroads
[Music]
our next question is from Emma Henderson
WKYC in Cleveland
am I there
all right we'll move on to Courtney
degeorge with Fox News
all right this is for everybody at the
press conference there's been a lot of
people who live in the area of Express
concern about quite back into their
homes despite being told that the air is
safe and the water is safe
um can you just speak a little bit to to
the validity of some of their concerns
that people are getting paid
um and what that might mean in terms of
long-term effects that this will have on
their bodies should they be concerned
about potential cancer clusters that
might arise as a result years down the
line and also uh governor
if you were to live in the area would
you feel comfortable moving back into
your home
let me take the first part
look look I I think that I would be
drinking the bottle of water
um and I would be continuing to uh
find out what the tests were showing as
far as the air
I would be alert and and concerned but I
think I would probably be back in my
house
I think that was a very good answer
truly I think the governor really
summarized the important points look we
we've got very good data as it relates
to the air quality and I think people
can feel very confident in that fact
coupled with the fact that there
continues to be air monitoring so that's
that's very good
we have no indication that the Municipal
Water Supply
is not safe however we do have testing
that is pending and I think it's a
relatively easy thing to do to use
bottled water for a short window of time
I think people should be confident that
multiple agencies both at the state and
the national level are very serious
about this are watching very closely and
are not allowing any wiggle room when it
comes to safety
what is that expected rate the next
question comes from Jordan Miller whbc
radio
all right thanks for taking my question
today uh my question is well Norfolk
Southern are they going to pay for any
um
autopsies for these animals that are
being found dead there's chickens that
people are worried about I know there's
a report of a dog in the East Palestine
area that has been circulating on social
media is that something that people can
confidently go to their vet for and turn
over a bill whether whether the vet
determines that the the animal the
livestock passed away because of the
chemical releases whether they determine
that or not can they rely on Norfolk
Southern to handle that bill yeah let me
ask the director of Agriculture to
answer that and to outline what the
procedure is there is a procedure
built into into our custom and to our
law
thank you Governor as far as the
question as far as the we the Ohio
Department of Agriculture we have a
Diagnostic lab and it is run by our
state vet Dr Summers and as far as the
policy and what we're telling the folks
as far as the the vets in the
communities I'm going to turn it over to
Dr Summers who's a specialist in that
area
welcome thank you Dr Dennis Summers
State veterinarian for Ohio yes just in
short to answer your question
animals that die for any reason
livestock pets first call should be to
your private veterinarian for to seek
guidance and and consultation for that
our animal disease Diagnostic lab is
here to serve the livestock Industries
and companion owners to do
necropsies and diagnostic testing for
any cause of death so we need to make
sure that we're following the
appropriate routing that those samples
that are being submitted or those
animals that may be found dead for any
reason
do come in through a veterinarian to our
animals use Diagnostic lab and we would
run them like we would any other normal
sample
thank you thank you
thank you thank you very much
our next question is from Dan derus
w-o-i-o in Cleveland
good afternoon Governor thanks for
taking the time for an update um the one
thing that hasn't been discussed today
is the giant column of Doomsday looking
smoke that went up after the
quote-unquote controlled release and
burn are we just supposed to believe
that that just disappeared uh that went
up into the atmosphere and and just went
away that had to have come down
somewhere there has to be a blanket of
whether it's soot or chemical whether it
was the wind sort of shifted that
evening so it kind of went uh instead of
just to the South East it kind of
started to go straight East and then a
little to the north I mean this has got
to be on the ground somewhere and if
we're talking livestock if we're talking
pets if we're talking kids out playing
there's no concern
more than a mile out 10 miles out 20
miles out 30 miles what happened to that
smoke and who can give those answers
let me let me see who who can if we've
got someone who can answer that
um
I don't think there's anyone here who's
volunteering so and look look what we're
trying to do is be very very careful
follow what the science is I don't know
what the science is in regard to that
but we'll try we'll try to get you an
answer if we can't get it today we'll
try to get you an answer later no
I I will so the only thing I could I can
say for sure is that we were monitoring
the air and this was a Rel a relatively
small area that we had quartered off and
told people that they need to leave
um we might we were monitoring the air
in real time when that went up uh in the
area right outside there uh and that
quality of air remained good
entire time
we later the next day went in of course
to the within that area of the red area
in the yellow area
and started measuring it and it was it
was good but at the moment when it went
up uh we were still getting readings my
understanding is they're still getting
readings right outside that that area
that indicated that it was it was good
but I cannot answer your question what
happens when that when that goes up
we'll see if we can get you an answer
these odors or Hayes and teams from both
uscpa don't think respond to those areas
throughout the night to verify them and
again no elevated readings didn't occur
rence constituents so so that did go on
throughout any of the areas where
citizens were reporting problems outside
of East Palestine
thank our next question is from Deanne
Johnson Youngstown Business Journal
all that is along the tracks I'm hearing
that they're talking about they're
Excavating it and pulling it out of
their uh two full questions the trains
continue to go through is that safe to
have those trains still going through
there if things are a little unstable
and secondly where is all the soil going
there's talk of things that are sitting
in these Palestine Park and large
containers is that where the soil is
being transported uh let me ask Kurt if
he knows
uh yes I think we're
um
the soil that is being excavated out is
there's three various uh three staging
paths on site within the footprint of
the stone Zone underneath those are
heavy plastic sealed liners or Burns any
water from either Enchanted soil or the
anticipated rain would be collected on a
continuous basis so that soil is being
managed it will be properly analyzed and
shipped off of disposal
um so that's what's going on in that as
far as train safety uh Norfolk Southern
has made us where we have to do all the
safety brings when working in those
areas they have complete control for
their tracks so anytime a train is
coming through it comes through at
reduced speed and the work has to stop
while the train passes so they have
complete control over that
a Wastewater storage those big blue
mobile storage uh tanks are beautiful 21
000 gallons capacity that we have them
at various staging areas
depending on the work locations like the
one you reference in the park is in the
event leader would have to pump material
from the creek into those again they are
safe they're sealed off you don't have
any direct access to everyone's side and
they also inside secondary containment
so in case something would happen to
those containers so that's how waste is
being managed on site and we work with
Norfolk Southern daily on that water
when we have people from our hazardous
waste again we're working with them
directly again Foods on the ground every
day
Eric final question today is from Dylan
Carr the Ashland Silvers
oh yeah thanks for taking my my question
here
um I we have readers in Ashland Richland
and Knox County
um they've expressed concern in air and
water quality in the aftermath aftermath
of this how concerned if at all should
these people be and if they shouldn't be
concerned even just a little bit what
steps should they take in terms of
obtaining testing kits or or anything
like that
we'll start with the surface water as
you saw from the the maps that we showed
the surface water is heading
um
Southeast to the Ohio River so the
locations that you mentioned should not
receive any uh
contaminated surface water in their area
but I'll let Dr vanderwaal talk about
the air
yeah I think that they can feel very
confident again we have to think about
the delusional effects that happen as
well as the predominant winds
um I I I would not consider those
communities to be at high risk and again
we've been very careful about the water
we will learn more as we are doing the
surrounding private water well testing
but again that they're they're they're
what they're underground water sources
are are not uh in the zone that we would
expect to be affected
we've had a we've had a request for you
to repeat the number and something oh
yes yeah sure sure I do have that and uh
let me I put my notes away so let me
grab it here it is three three zero
let's see here
oh here it is sorry
[Music]
three three zero
eight four nine
three nine one nine I'll do that one
more time three three zero eight four
nine three nine one nine
anybody else
find positive tests and private Wells
so a part of the the challenge is uh
people signing up this is a voluntary
um activity so if you've got a private
water system and have not called the
number to get on the list to get tested
um please do uh the turnaround time does
not appear to be long but it is a matter
of days so we'd like people to sign up
for that testing uh in that area as soon
as possible
yeah
this is related
I guess
um
there were reports that you were not
necessarily looking at any sort of
action regarding the adjutant general
And the reporter who was arrested is
there going to be any
anything after this well as you know
this matters turned over by the local
County prosecutor to the attorney
general
I remained I have the same opinion I had
the first day and that is that I would
hope that charges would be dropped
I think that would be the best thing
you know I whatever happened after the
general walked away
the reality is that the reporter should
not have been stopped period so it
shouldn't even start it that way and I
understand you know people may have
different feelings about what happened
afterwards but the initial the initial
stop the initial confrontation or the
initial contact never should have
occurred so taking that into
consideration it seems to me that
everyone would be better off if we just
you know if if the Attorney General
could see fit not to proceed with any
kind of prosecution if you talk to the
edge in general about the initial
confrontation
yes
yes look I think I think the
the general uh you know regrets that
um
you know I explained to him you know how
press conferences work and that frankly
that sometimes during a live press
conference someone will will be
reporting directly someone could be
right now standing back there and
Reporting if they wanted to
know and that's the they have the right
to they have the right to deliver the
news however they want to deliver the
news so yes we've had we've had a
conversation tonight and he you know
look he regrets the whole situation so
we will continue to uh keep you apprised
uh we will not do we don't plan at least
on doing a press conference every day uh
what we do plan on doing is every day at
least once a day uh release the
information any new information that we
have so you can expect that to come from
the governor's office you can expect
that to come as a kind of a day summary
of what is going on that does not mean
there won't be other information that's
posted in different forms but coming out
of the governor's office we're going to
try to summarize it once a day get it to
you in time so that you can utilize that
so thank you all very much
[Music]
all right